good afternoon um
my name is jurgen reist and i'm a
professor at the college of veterinary
medicine at kansas state university
and i will talk today on the
susceptibility
transmission and reinfection
of domestic acts with sars cov2
all the work we do is in a bsl 3x
facility which is shown here
the biosecurity research institute at
kansas state
so before i start i will acknowledge all
the people which were involved in these
studies
this takes a village to do all this work
in my laboratory there are many people
involved and i want to mention bianca
natasha daniel david and jesse
mainly for
really great work and the chang lab at
kansas state to that's the pseudo
viruses
i want to mention when shulma who is at
university of missouri now
bill wilson from usda here in town and
at alfo garcia
from mount sinai and the
uh immune immunohistochemistry and in
situ was done at luciana state by
uh mariano in dudini and
uh without the funding of internal funds
in bath national bioet transition fan
funds the nih uh with the
centers of excellence of influenza
research and surveillance concept grant
and department of homeland security this
work would not be
possible so i want to today
um the next 40 minutes discuss um the
outline this is the outline of my
presentation
why do we do have a cat model for
corvit-19
um how is these uh how then
what are the results of a primary
infection of these animals
um what what are the results if we
reinfect these animals after three weeks
with south korea too
and then at the end i want to discuss
what are the environmental contamination
issues
in in a cat environment infected cat
environment
and it's the source kovi too genetically
stable
in cats so this is the rationale of
why we just developed this kovit 19
cad model we all know that most likely
the sarsko v2 was transmitted
from bats either directly or
via an intermediate host for example the
pangolin
into humans and it got and it's very
efficiently transmitted
among humans and it caused the 2020
pandemic
the what is known now that not only it
goes from animals to humans but it also
goes back
this is a zoonotic transmission it has a
reverse
sonosis it can be transmitted back to
animals
from humans to animals and for example
here we have lions and tigers
which have been shown to become infected
by
uh call with 19 positive
caretakers in the new york zoo we have
docs in many countries in the world
which have been shown to be infected in
covet 19 households
the same is true with domestic cats we
have a lot of
cases where in core with 19 households
cats
got infected and were shown to to shed
virus and in one study in wuhan they
found
15 percent of the animals which they
tested zero positive
four south kore two antibodies
and we know uh from several outbreaks in
mink farms in the netherlands in the u.s
in denmark that mink are highly
susceptible to this virus and they can
show
severe clinical signs and even mortality
and there is a
report on a mink to human in two cases
in
link to human transmission
however the detection of south korea
ii and all these animals i mentioned
here is rather limited
considering the extent the extent of the
human pandemic
so this is our first study in uh where
we did primary infection and reinfection
of cats and i will go through in this
diagram and how we set up this
experimental model so we have two
control caps which we necropsied
before we or before we did the
infection study in cats we had six
cats which we challenged powers
and intranasal simultaneously with 10 to
the six
um tcid50 of the u.s strain wa1 2020
and we used this where they were
separated in two cages in two groups
with two
three cats each uh we added
after one day one sentinel per cage
into two sentinels in total after one
day of infection
and then on day four we necropsied
two infected cats on day seven we
necropsied another two infected cats
on day 21 we necropsied another infected
cat
and then we had three cats left which we
then
reinfected with the same dose of the
same virus
intranasally and powers and then we
followed these animals for four days
and then we did necropsy and looked for
pathology macroscopic microscopic
pathology
and all the virology associated um
with this study these are the animal
rooms we
keep these animals these are bsl three
egg animal rooms
and we keep them in these cages four
cats
package three principal and one sentinel
animals
and we also do a lot of environmental
studies as shown here with an air sample
on the right
and in order to handle cats
we also house them before we
sample them and bleed them in single
cages as also seen here on the right
these are our sampling timelines and
um we start with infection and day zero
with the sentinels on day one added to
the
principal animals and we did body
temperature and clinical signs
daily we did body weight on every second
or third day
and then we also did nasal oropharyngeal
rectal swabs
every two or three days
and then on the similarly we did
air and environmental samples on various
days past inoculation
we did black collection also in every
second or third days
and we did on day four seven and day 21
we necropsied animals
and we did during necro afternoon after
euthanasia we did nasal washes
we pulled the lung the entire lung and
did poncho alveolar lavage fluid valve
and we sampled the entire upper and
lower respiratory tract the gi tract the
central nervous system various nerves
the eyes the inner ear
major organ urine feces therapy spinal
fluid whereas lymph nodes
and bone marrow in total we have ten
cats
two control cats six principal infected
cats
and two sentinels um
in blood analysis we did an entire blood
analysis
at various time points post infection
and we used the webscan hm5 to do that
we did white blood cells lymphocyte
monocytes neutrophils
eosinophils basophils red blood cells
we determined hematocrit thermoclean
hemoglobin
and platelets and all these data
were in the normal range except for the
platelets
where we saw numbers reduced
starving at day five post infection
we did viral rna detection pcr
that we used the cdc pcr technology or
technique or probes and primers and we
sampled the blood that various time
points was an infection
and with our infected animals we did not
find
any positive uh blood any any rna in the
blood of these
animals principally infected animals in
red and the same was through
for our sentinel animals we did not find
any our anemia in any of the animals
tested in this study
we then did nasal swaps in nasal swabs
the story is different the infected
animals in red we see already
positive these are viral rna
copy numbers genome copy numbers we see
it already in day one
it's maintained until day 10 post
inoculation
and negative on day 14 and with our
sentinel animals
we find the first positive ones on day
three
and it's also maintained until day 10 uh
post inoculation and negative on day 14
and day 21.
if we do nasal washes and we do that at
necropsy days we see on day four day
seven high loads of
viral rna in the nasal washes on both
animals necklace feet
but none on day 21 post inoculation
and similarly if we do poncho alveolar
lavage fluid on day four and day seven
both animals are positive and the one on
day 21 is negative
we do oral french pharyngeal swaps too
and here we see again like similarly to
the nasal
swabs on day one the principal infected
animals are positive for day one and
maintain
positivity until day 10 and are negative
for day 14 and 21
and the sentinels are also turning
positive at day three but are
already end day five but are already
negative on day seven
throughout the rest of these uh the
other two weeks
the story is different when we look at
the rectal swaps and these are animals
four and a half to five months old we
see
very nice shedding already on day three
indeed it's a little bit later than with
the nasal and our referential
on day three post inoculation in the
principal animals
and maintained up to day 14 longer than
with the other
swaps and then negative on day 21
if we look in our sentinels we see a
similar kinetic
even higher genomic
copy numbers than
compared with the principal infected
animals but all negative at a21
we also looked at viral rna in different
tissues in orange we see these two
animals uh
on day four post uh challenge in red
the two animals on day seven post um
uh challenge and day twenty one this one
animal and 21 days
plus challenge and as shown here in the
upper respiratory tract
all of these animals are already
positive on day four
and maintained positivity throughout day
21
however on day 21 the virus rna load is
lower
when we look in the lower respiratory
tract we see a similar
results all animals are positive on day
four and also more or less on day
seven post challenge and some of them
only some of the tissues
are maintained positive on day 21
like bronchi and some of the lung lobes
but the maturity is negative on day 21.
the lymphatic tissue shows that
tonsils tracheal branch lymph nodes
mesenteric lymph nodes are positive
already in day four
and maintained until day 21 where our
spleen
is not positive on day four but positive
on day seven
and day 21 post challenge
if we look at other tissues like gi
tract
liver heart kidney bone marrow olfactory
bubbles
cerebral spinal fluid we see day four
most cases in most of these organs we
see positivity
and many of these are already negative
in day 21 like
in the gi tract in the liver in the
heart
and in the bone marrow and the cerebral
spinal fluid
histopathology and iic we mainly
see on day four and day seven
is the inflammation of submucosal plants
as shown here on day four and then day
seven
um we don't see anything obviously in
the mock infected animals
uh very normal uh submucosa glands and
the same is true
on day 21 and when we look at the right
side here within
inside of hybridization we see very nice
on day four
and day seven we see positive reactivity
in these submucosal gland areas
of the bronchi
and if we use immunohistochemistry it's
confirmed in the same area
and everything and that's only on day
four and day seven
post challenge and the tissue is
negative
again at day 21 post inoculation
the animals are able to develop
neutralizing antibodies
starting at day 10 post inoculation and
still maintain it until day 21
post challenge and this summarizes
this first part of my presentation
the primary infection of cats with
saskov2 and this is recently uh posted
in bio archives and here is the
website for it we could show that if we
infect text
via the intranasal powers root
simultaneously with 10 to the 60 ccid50
we do not observe up with clinical signs
we saw a day two temperature temperature
spike
but uh we really that's the only thing
we saw no real
clinical signs and these are four and a
half five months old animals
we did not see any significant changes
in blood cell parameters
or bio markers the only thing we saw was
thrombocytopenia
above five days post-inoculation there
was no r anemia in the blood
the urine was also negative we saw
transcend shedding of viral rna
through the oral nasal and rectal
cavities
and we saw viral rna regular
regularly at the upper respiratory tract
lymphatic tissues
and olfactory bulk on all three days
we sampled these tissues on day 4
7 and 21 on day 21 we did not see it
anymore
in most cases in the lower respiratory
tract in various lung lobes in the gi
tract in the liver heart
therapy spinal fluid and bone marrow we
saw microscopic and microscopic lung
trachea lesions and um
the it is a trans tracheal bronchiolitis
we could not see or did not recognize
any interstitial pneumonia
and this tracheal bonudinite is is
associated with the presence of viral
rna
and antigen on days four and seven but
not on day twenty one
and the transmission from the principal
infected animals to the sentinel was
very
efficient within two days
we still have to finalize our virus
titrations and suctionoric rna analysis
our early spots and our rna feed on
various tissues we collected
at necropsy we also
addressed that the questions the
question are cats
which were infected with saskov2
susceptible or protected
from reinfection with that virus
and we did two independent experiments
one on the four
four and a half five months old animals
and one on seven-month-old cats
and we inoculated these animals
three weeks after primary infection
this is our first cat reinfection
experiment and we
sampled we did it the following ways on
day 21 which is day zero
past second challenge we
reinfected three cats which were left
over from the initial experiment
with 10 to the sixth tcid 50
stars cov2 again intranasal and pairs
and then we followed them over four days
the clinical signs body weight we
swapped them on day zero one three and
four
we uh did also air sampling blood
collection
and we did necropsy and they four and
collected these
same tissues we collected previously for
the primary infection
and these are the results if we looked
at
viral rna detection in nasal swaps as
shown here
the principle infected in red is
sentinels in blue
and in green now we see the reinfected
animal so there was some
shedding on day one rna setting but the
animals were negative on day three
and four if we looked at nasal washes
on day four at nakupsi there was one
animal which was positive but the others
were negative
if we looked at valve all both were
negative
at the time of necropsy four days
past secondary or plus three infection
we did the same we look for rna in the
oropharyngeal swabs and in rectal swabs
and these are the oropharyngeal swabs
infected in red
sentiments in blue primary infected
and here are the reinfected we couldn't
find anything in the or in the
oropharyngeal swaps in the reinfected
animals
in the rectal swabs the situation was a
little different
we could find in all animals on day
three and day four
they one three and four we could find
rna
and was still present at the time of
necropsy
we also looked at various tissues
similarly as
in with our primary infection this is
the upper respiratory tract and as you
see here
in many of these animals
um sacrificed on day four
post-reinfection or um
before dp2c and many of the tissues of
these animals in double respiratory
tract we've still found
rna at after reinfection
if we looked at the same at the lower
respiratory tract tissue as shown here
most of them were negative only a couple
like francei
and some um lung
lobes were still positive the story is
different when we look at lymphatic
lymphatic tissues
similar tonsils lymph node spleen
many of these tissues in these three
infected animals were still
positive four days after reinfection
and when we did other tissues like the
gi tract
liver etc we found that
still some of these tissues were
positive on day four
post reinfection like the heart
like the olfactory bulb and the bone
marrow
in terms of neutralizing antibodies at
the time of
inoculate re-inoculation day 21 post
challenge day zero dp2c
all of these three animals here in brown
we reinfected had neutralizing titles of
about 100
100 and these were maintained throughout
the
four days it doesn't seem there is an
animalistic response
we looked at the histopathological
changes
in these animals on the left trachea
with h and e
and uh inside the hybridization and on
the right franchise
and if you as you can see in the upper
part are the mock infected animals in
the middle out of
the primary infected animals on day four
post
challenge and in the lower row we have
the
um reinfected animals also on day four
post reinfection and as you can see
the on day four post primary infection
you see
these adenitis associated with the
rna in the within the submucosal plants
in both trajec as well as fungi and if
we look at the reinfected animals we
don't see any viral antigen present
in the respective tissues and no
inflammation
in the submucosal plants
we did a secondary infection experiment
where we used this time we used five
caps
which we reinfected and we added one day
after reinfection two sentinel cats
to see whether the reinfection could
lead
to transmission of virus to sentinel
cats
and we followed these animals for up to
14 days
again with body daily body temp and
clinical signs
body weights we swap them again with
nasal or
refrigerant rectal swabs uh
we also took blood
at various time points plus three
infection and then we did necropsy
two animals two out of these five on day
four like before
uh two out of these uh five
reinfected animals on day seven
and then on day 14 two weeks after we
infection we necropsied
one of the reinfected animals and we end
the two
sentinel cats
so what did we see this these studies
are not
yet all the data are not in yet so i
would just focus on the data we have
and the most important was nasal swabs
these are in red against
again the infected and the sentinel
animals on day one already positive in
primary infected uh principal infected
animals day three in the
sentinels and if we look at the uh
reinfected animals we see positive free
positivity uh already on day one
and it's also positive for day four and
already negative for day five
um the sentinels
throughout the entire time we could not
find
any positive nasal swabs and also none
of the nasal swabs beyond day five was
positive
beyond day four was positive
for rna in the reinfected animal
if you look at nasal swabs on day four
both animals which we necropsied were
negative however we saw really in both
animals at day seven
we see positivity and all the three
animals
were negative on day 14. including the
sentinels
similarly if we look at poncho alveolar
lavage fluid
um they were negative in the reinfected
animals on day 4
7 and 21 and 14 and also the two
sentinels were
negative on day 14.
we looked at virus neutralizing
antibodies and here on day 21
was primary challenge the the
five animals we reach reinfected are
shown in a
with the brown uh background they all
had antibody titers
neutralizing antibody titles against the
um
uh south cov2 and our sentinel animals
were negative
and when we looked at the time of
necropsy
they had still antibody tidal day four
the two animals at day seven the two
animals we necropsied
and at day 14 post
secondary infection and
none of our sentinels however
zero converted interestingly
on day 7 and day 14
the antibody titled titles compared to
the
reinfection title was higher so there
seemed to be an anonymistic
response but it's very clear that our
fentanyl animals which were in the room
did not seroconvert so apparently the
virus
shedding these reinfected animals had
did not lead
to infection and seroconversion of these
sentinel
texts so this summarizes the second part
of my talk
this after reinfection of primary
infected cats
we could not see obvious clinical signs
and no
viremia no change in blood cell
parameters
we had limited rna shedding especially
via the upper respiratory tract in the
nasal
nasal cavities but also in oral cavities
especially in the second experiment i
didn't have time to show and in the gi
tract
we had limited rna in nasal washes
and in the bulk and in the lower
respiratory tract
and we had significant rna still after
reinfection and upper respiratory
tissues lymphatic tissues and various
organs
however at postmortem and we only have
done it in the first
reinfection experiment on day four
post-secondary infection we could not
see any enhancement of respiratory
disease and no pathology
and also no antigen or rna in lung
tissues
we saw an amnestic immune response after
we infection
especially in the second experiment
where we had day seven
and day 14 um a post-secondary infection
we did not see it in earlier day day on
day four
however and most importantly the
shedding of
rna by these three infected animals we
are not able to
induce disease um
viral rna set significant rna shedding
or infection of the sentinels
because they state they they stayed
sero-negative
even two weeks after co-mingling with
the
re-infected cats
so we conclude from these that sars cov2
infection in cats
induces at humeral immune responses
maybe also cell mediated immune
responses
which we have to still test which
provided protection against three
challenge
and so this means that immunological
approaches to prevention
of south kore ii and treatment of karsov
v2 may be possible
okay this brings me to the last part of
my presentation
environmental contamination and sas coe2
genome stability
so we looked because this is a important
question for public and veterinary
health what are the hot spots in an area
where cats south korea ii infected cats
are housed
so we took swaps from various areas
within the cage on the on the cage bars
water bowls footballs in the litter box
cat toys
our boots outside we did air sampling we
did floor
samples treatment table the cat fur etc
and viral rna load is shown from green
low
to red high and this is a summary here
hot spots we found are the food bowls
the treatment table
we find still very high loads and cage
bars
in the bed where the animals sleep in
the water bowl
and significant uh viral load rna load
on cat fur
on the shelf or the cat toys and less
viral load in boots room air and in the
litter
so an important question for us was to
determine whether
south kov2 infection in cats can
generate
adaptation adaptive mutations
so to re-mind you
how these studies were done we used the
strain usa wa1
2020 passaged it three times in various
six cells
and then we transmitted or infected cats
in this case these studies are the four
and a half five month old cats by
intranasal powers
uh inoculation and then we ask the
question
do they maintain is the consensus
sequence which is known for
wa1 2020 maintaining cats
and how did we do that we did next
generation sequencing using a
tiled amplification
approach next generation sequencing
approach called arctic
version 3 and we sequenced these by an
illumina nxseq
instrument so this all the data
we did find in the
and very important we found two
mutations
amino acid substitutions in the of one a
and one b but more importantly
we found within the s the spike protein
an insertion and this insertion is a
12 nucleotide insertion in the
ntd the n-terminal domain
of the spike protein and the amino acid
sequence
inserted is k l r
s and this insertion was found in
all six infected primary
infected cats so we found an insertion
in the spike
on um amino acid
position 215 a klrs
insertion when we looked at the
structure of the spike protein
and where this insertion is located it
is shown here
on the left you see the spike the trimer
of the spike protein in green you see
the receptor binding domain and
underneath in blue
the n-terminal domain we did then
um structural modeling and to predict
how this insertion will look like and as
you see now on the right the vial
type is on the left side and the
mutant virus or the mutant ntd is on the
right side
you see that these klrs these basic
residues
they determine or they build
a surface exposed loop here shown in red
so structural modeling predicts that
this
leads to a surface exposed loop within
the internal domain
of the spike protein
we then wanted to determine how the
mutant virus the percentage of the
mutant virus
changes within a defined sample
from the stock virus why are the various
passages
in p cells and we use p3 to inoculate it
in cats
in various cell cultures from swine
and so on and into hamsters and here are
on the left now shown the cell culture
data so this insertion goes up
to up to passage three we have it's
still not the consensus sequence but
about 25 30 percent
of the p3 passage
virus in viral cells contains this klrs
sequence
and when we infect
porcine kidney cells porcine swine
testicle cells
these this mutation or this
the mutant virus almost disappears
similarly in human liver cells huh
seven however it's maintained its
percentage in human kidney cells
if we look in cats and this is the
inoculum
and we look at day 1 and then at day 3
5 etc and different tissues we find
that the percentage of these mutant
increases and becomes the consensus
sequence after b3
post inoculation it gets and this is
shown throughout various tissues
gi tissue rectal swabs respiratory
and even in here in respiratory tissue
if we do the same with hamsters you can
see that
we have an increase also in this in this
mutant sequence if we transmit that
virus
uh that p3 viral stock virus into
hamsters
we the most important or very important
question is now what
how will neutralizing antibody recognize
that
mutant versus the wild type and in order
to do that we developed together with dr
chang at cancer state lentivirus-based
viruses which either express the wild
type spike
wild type spike or the mutant spike
protein and then we tested them either
in a gfp or the surface
based readout system and for this
test sorry we use cacera various cat
sierra
rapid serum and two human syrah
and on the right here you see the wild
type titles and uh
all in the middle the wildside title
titles
and on the right in in brown uh with the
brown background you see the mutant
virus tires and as you can see for the
cat
for the rabbit and for the human sierra
there are not much differences
maybe a little bit for the human sierra
where if you hide a higher title
with a mutant versus the wild-type virus
but it seems to be there are no
differences in neutralization titles
between
using the mutant virus versus
the wild-type pseudo-virus
we also developed right away a
diagnostic test as shown here
and we have a common forward and reverse
primer and then we have a wild type
probe and the mutant probe and as you
see here in a mixed population it
recognizes wild type
in blue and mutant virus in red
in a mixed population and if we have
black purified wild type
it only recognizes the wild type virus
and if you have blood
block purified mutant virus it only
recognizes the mutant
virus so these rt diagnostic
rtq's qpcr diagnostic test is able to
differentiate specifically and highly
specifically
insensitive between the mutant with the
insertion
and the wild-type virus so this brings
me to the end
of this part we have shown that
the environmental contamination by south
korea two infected cats is mainly in the
food and water bowls
the treatment table cage bars and the
bed
and we have shown that the virus
which is transmitted from um
into cats acquire the
that the virus which is transmitted
amplified
for three passages in viral cells
selects a mutant virus
which has a four amino acid insertion a
klrs insertion
and we found that in all cats after
three days past
inoculation and this insertion is
present in also in the viral stock
material which we have shown but in less
percentage it's not the consensus
sequence however it's the consensus
sequence in the cat
and structural modeling predicts that
this insertion consists of basic
residues
in a surface exposed loop
neutralization as is done so far with
pseudo viruses
and using positive human cat and rapid
sierra
do not show differences in tidal between
using a wild type or mutant virus for
the virus neutralization tests
and in order to do future epidemics in
epidemiological studies
we have developed the diagnostic essay
for wild type mutant virus
which can be done in a single tube
reaction
again uh this can only be done uh
with many collaborations and i have
mentioned
my collaborators at kansas state
university of missouri usda
mount sinai and luciana state already
and it cannot be done without the
funding provided by
the different agencies listed here thank
you very much for your attention